the white picket fence space for
entertaining acres of land to call your
own
these were characteristics of the
American dream but is it still a dream
worth chasing should you buy a home or
rent we're here at the White House at
six Woods Lane in East Hampton Long
Island you could own this place for the
list price of twelve point five million
dollars with a 30-year fixed-rate
mortgage at three point nine nine one
percent Interest you'd pay nearly forty
seven thousand dollars a month and
that's not including closing costs
homeownership insurance or property
taxes now this kind of place might be a
little pricey for you but the same
principles apply at much lower levels
when you're considering whether to rent
or buy a home now before I break
something in here let's get back to the
studio to buy or not to buy that is the
question we pulled our YouTube audience
and they had a lot to say one person
said owning a house should not be
thought of as an investment more like
something between an asset and a
liability someone else shared a pretty
common sentiment these days that student
loans would prevent them from everybody
go home another said abolish private
property altogether but ok a majority of
you think ownership is the way to go and
who can blame them people think of
buying a home as part of the American
dream
the driver of middle-class wealth a
sound investment vehicle renting a place
is less romantic throwing money away
every month on a place to rest your head
and keep your stuff but that calculus is
changing to help us run down the reasons
why you may want to rent and not buy it
I spoke to financial planner Roger MA
so can you tell me why renting is not
throwing your money away well I think
the flipside is why is buying not
wasting money and I think that's a myth
that when you buy a lot of your money is
building equity but that's just not the
case your monthly payment and the
upfront and the backend costs of buying
are wasted money as well you've got
mortgage interest homeowner's insurance
property taxes potentially homeowners
association fees yeah not to mention the
huge closing costs on the front end and
the back end if you don't plan to say in
the same area for at least five years it
probably makes more sense to rent and
that's because of those large closing
costs right you need to give your home a
sufficient amount of time to potentially
increase in value feel like the
generation now growing is maybe more
likely to be on the move definitely
between the ages of 22 and 40 the
average person changes jobs every one to
two years so there are changing a fair
amount so I think having the flexibility
to change jobs could be reasons to rent
instead of other right and that's okay
there's no shame in renting and if you
look around the United States depending
on where you live it might actually be
more affordable Adham Data Solutions
publishes a yearly affordability index
of buying versus renting and in most
places 59% to be exact
real estate prices are outpacing rentals
in fact in all 18 of the most populous
counties in America it's more affordable
to rent than buy let's be real for a lot
of people the choice of renting versus
buying may not even be yours especially
if you're young
I talked to Bloomberg reporter Patrick
Clark about the unique problems facing
potential homebuyers let's talk about
the unique hindrances that may be new
home buyers might face there's not
enough homes they can afford that would
be a big problem at the very most basic
there's an affordability gap a decade
after
foreclosure crisis we're still building
homes not just of where they were at the
peak bubble madness but still below the
number of new homes that we were adding
in like the mid 90s the construction
that is happening has been skewed
towards the high end that is sort of
pressured on the other side by maybe
aged people growing older and maybe not
moving out of their homes there's two
different ways you could get listings
how you could build new homes or you can
have pumps that we're already occupied
right hit the market there's some
question of whether people want to stay
in their own homes and quote-unquote age
in place older people staying in their
homes longer is an issue right so
there's some gridlock in the housing
market this generation is nowis addled
with more more kind of burdens than
previously was the case way more there's
like more than 1.5 trillion dollars of
student loan debt outstanding yikes the
deck is certainly stacked against this
generation but that long standing
elusive goal of homeownership seems so
tempting all in all I'd have to put it
this way if you have your heart set on a
home ownership nobody's going to stand
in your way
but you probably don't need to sweat it
too much either if you don't
that was probably expensive
[Music]
you
you